[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bon jour à tout jeu
nous présente nous sommes cinq lycéens
porte-parole représentant un groupe de
vingt élèves ayant suivi une option
scolaire nommé demain c'est nous je
suppose que vous avez déjà entendu
parler des migrations climatiques la
disparition d'espèces animales des fonte
des glaces de l'amplification de la des
catastrophes naturelles
tu es la montée des eaux ou bien de
l'apparition de nouvelles maladies
tropicales en europe
ainsi nous sommes déjà tous victimes du
changement climatique
aujourd'hui les scientifiques sont tous
d'accord pour affirmer que nous sommes
touchés par le changement climatique via
toutes ses conséquences et bien d'autres
aussi ils sont unanimes sur le fait que
les humains sont la cause directe du
changement climatique qui n'est pas une
feuille technique
[Musique]
cependant le fait que nous ayons des
incertitudes ne signifie pas que nous
devons rester dans l'inaction devons
donc agir et c'est ce que nous avons
fait en nous rassemblant pour en
entendre apprendre et comprendre plus
sur le changement climatique
nous avons donc choisi de suivre
l'option scolaire demain si nous car
c'est un projet qui a pour but de
sensibiliser aux causes et aux
conséquences du changement climatique
pour aller par la suite des coups clés
teasé sur le terrain contrairement à ce
que beaucoup peuvent penser certains ont
choisi d'intégrer cette option pour
l'aspect humain et non scientifique
en fait le changement climatique est
trop souvent résumée par des chiffres et
des graphiques mais ce n'est pas que ça
ce n'est pas vraiment ça ah oui c'est
bien d'avoir des chiffres alarmants mais
pour réellement les comprendre pour
comprendre leur impact pour comprendre
que nous sommes concernés et que nous
sommes tous responsables pour comprendre
que tout dépend de nous et de nos
actions on comprendre l'engagement que
cela représente
où les enjeux de ce phénomène pour
comprendre qu'il faut communiquer par
les ont sensibilisés vous comprendre
tout ça et pour réellement comprendre le
changement climatique il faut avant
d'être un scientifique être un humain
qui sait faire preuve d'empathie et de
sensibilité
durant l'année de troisième où nous
avons suivi cette option nous avons
d'abord étudier les conséquences puis
les causes du changement climatique
nous avons aussi eu la chance de pas
d'échangé avec plusieurs scientifiques
et de mener des recherches pour
concrétiser le tout nous sommes partis
dans un incroyable voyage oswald battre
pendant dix jours le cheval barbe ou
spitzberg est située à environ 1000 km
du pôle nord au dessus du cercle polaire
tout en haut du globe cette destination
a été choisi car le seul barbe est une
maquette à échelle planétaire du
changement climatique
là bas les glaciers la banquise fondent
à vue d'oeil et tout le monde vraiment
tout le monde du plus petit au plus
grand sont impactés par ce changement
dans leur quotidien
nous nous y sommes donc rendus
un des moments qui nous a tous marqués
fut l'arrivée au cheval barbe lorsque
nous étions dans l'avion presque au
moment de l'atterrissage
nous avons pu voir par le hublot de
magnifiques paysages
imaginez-vous des terres désertiques de
la neige partout presque aucune activité
humaine
c'était incroyable surtout qu'à ce
moment là nous avons eu la chance de
voir des aurores boréales
si la première fois que l'on envoyait
c'était si magnifique et si
extraordinaire je ne sais pas si vous en
avez déjà vu mais c est un spectacle
magique
lorsque nous sommes arrivés aux albums
il faisait environ moins 20 degrés du
coup pour nous c'est une température
complètement inhabituelles dans la bio
on a été obligé d'enfiler et doudounes
polaire et par cas pour ne pas avoir
froid
ensuite après avoir récupéré nos
affaires à l'aéroport on est sorti et
directement en sortant n'a pu voir un
immense york avec son glaciers et de la
banquise et pour nous tous c'est un
moment déclic et on s'est tous rendu
compte qu'on était privilégié de vivre
cette aventure là au delà des rencontres
scientifiques qui nous ont tous
énormément marqués ça peut paraître nier
on a réellement été touché par la beauté
de la nature là bas sans pollution
sonore ou visuelle sans aucun déchet
venant gâcher tous ces paysages c'est
assez compliqué à décrire car on a vu
tellement de choses c'était à la fois
blanc blanc comme la neige et montagne
est classé la lumière colère c'était
doux lumineau épuré silencieux mais
c'était aussi vivant de part les maisons
couleur locale les nuances orange et du
soir où les ombres tapantes je ne sais
pas si j'arrive à vous faire visualiser
mais ce n'est pas le plus important
ce que j'aimerais vous faire comprendre
c'est qu'on a réellement été
sensibilisés notre point de vue il a
réellement changé mais d'un point de vue
beaucoup plus artistique
vous vous imaginez être dans un pays où
il fait jour de début mai à mi septembre
je vous avoue qu'au début j'avais
beaucoup de mal à y croire
j'ai été totalement déstabilisé qui se
fait jour à une heure du matin lors de
notre arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la lumière le jour
il avançait de plus en plus sur tous les
jours il s'allongeait de plus en plus
dont tous les jours environ on à en
gagner 20 minutes donc à bout d'un
moment la luminosité environ aux
alentours de 18h et stagner donc on
avait plus du tout de repères temporels
on n'arrêtait pas de regarder sur notre
montre on peut le dire on est totalement
désorienté j'espère que non et s'ils
sont à travers nos aussi à vous faire
voyager avec nous qu'elle serait égoïste
ne pas vous faire profiter de ses
magnifiques paysages qui est ce que
bientôt de disparaître peut-être que la
banquise des glaciers les rênes
les phoques et les morses tout ce qui
nous a émerveillés va disparaître et
bien c'est cette idée qui a donné à la
plupart d'entre nous l'envient de
combattre le changement climatique
on a vraiment pris conscience que face à
l'immensité du svalbard
l'homme est petit mais que son pouvoir
destructeur est vraiment démesurée par
rapport à la place qu'il occupe
aujourd'hui au delà des pandas qui font
la une des ong est une espèce sur cinq
est en voie de disparition
même ici en charente maritime comme
certains amphibiens des plantes ou même
des petits mammifères disparaissent or
chacun a son rôle à jouer dans les
écosystèmes ou dans la chaîne
alimentaire
donc ils ont un faux pas qui
disparaissent quoi alors
contrairement à nous les animaux n'ont
que peu de facultés d'adaptation au
changement climatique ne les entrées non
pas dans ce qui serait la sixième
r d'extinction de masse de cette planète
je ne sais pas si vous en êtes rendu
compte mais chacun d'entre nous a été
marquée différemment par les expériences
que nous avons vécu chacun a enregistré
différentes paroles différents paysages
différents visages que d'autres avaient
peut-être oublié parce qu'on est tous
différent ici j'aimerais faire un
parallèle que vous n'allez peut-être pas
comprendre tout de suite avec une oeuvre
du fabuleux auteurs français qui antoine
de saint-exupéry qui a écrit le petit
prince
je pense que la plupart d'entre vous le
connaissent ces neuf cas c'est connu
j'ai pas faire une critique des rg pas
faire un résumé parce qu'une c'est ni
l'endroit ni moment mais j'ai juste
revenir sur un moment marquant c'est le
tout début quand le narrateur un
aviateur arrive dans le désert son avion
s'est crashé et rencontrent pour la
première fois le petit prince celui-ci
lui dit s'il vous plaît dessine moi un
mouton donc l'aviateur il est surpris
mais il décide de le faire d'obtempérer
et il ya des signes un de 300 que jamais
ça ça convaincre le petit prince alors
il décide de lui dessiner une boîte et
lui dit ton mouton et les l'attend hélas
le petit prince ludique c'est
merveilleux c'est exactement ce qu'il
attendait un changement climatique c'est
pareil on peut pas s'attendre en
présentant toujours de la même manière
que tout le monde soit touché de la même
manière chacun ses passions chacun à son
imaginaire cette boîte est tombé tous
les moutons possible parce qu'elle est
l'imaginaire le changement climatique
pour qu'elles touchent tout le monde il
faudrait qu'elles touchent tous les
domaines que tout le monde soit impacté
de la même manière et passer le k mais
pour tout le monde le comprenne mot
consent scène il faut qu on se documente
et si tout le monde comprend qu'on peut
pas dé laisser aux autres le fait de
s'occuper du changement climatique qu'on
peut pas dire ce mot grave en toisant
c'est l'écologie après tout on peut pas
si tout le monde le comprend on pourra
tous mettre au service de cette cause
notre imagination et trouver des
solutions aussi différentes
eva ce que nous sommes et que le
changement climatique est simplement
pourquoi nous réfléchissions aujourd'hui
climatique faut bien sûr suivre
l'actualité rester informé en parler
autour de nous mais il faut avant tout
être éduqués dans ce sens il faut
laisser aux jeunes le moyen de
s'exprimer
leur laisser la parole et ne pas les
censurer ni les dénigrer car ils sont
jeunes
oui nous sommes jeunes mais nous ne
sommes pas que ça parce que la jeunesse
changer chose plomb les jeunes plants
addénergie et d'espoir et plus on peut
changer le monde
ce sont des jeunes par exemple qui ont
organisé commencé des manifestations de
mai 68 et je suis certain que dans le
public des personnes ont vécu cet
événement
mais là on veut pas vous parler
politique on veut pas vous donner notre
avis sur cet événement on veut plus vous
montrez vous donner un exemple concret
que la jeunesse peut avoir des idées et
peut les faire valoir
parce que c'est cette jeunesse qui va
bientôt être victime du changement
climatique c'est cette jeunesse qui en
quelques années entrera dans une société
qui doit faire face au changement
climatique
c'est pour ça qu'il faut nous laisser le
droit de nous exprimer et de pensée nous
souhaitons aussi obtenir le droit à la
parole et aux moyens d'agir
[Musique]
aux problèmes de l'éducation s'ajoute un
enjeu fondamental celui du rassemblement
l'unicité fait un facteur essentiel dans
notre projet mais le fait qu'on était un
groupe nous a permis d'avoir des idées
qu'on n'aurait peut-être pas eu tout
seul aujourd'hui et depuis le début de
l'option demain c'est nous nous sommes
ensemble en groupe venu pour vous parler
du changement climatique
nous avons compris que c'était la
solution doivent donc décidé de
continuer à nous regrouper en créant
l'association demain c'est nous
aujourd'hui on vous a présenté un projet
qui nous tenait à coeur parce qu'il nous
a changé il a aussi changé le point de
vue que nous portions sur le monde
on vous a présenté les enjeux de ce
changement climatique ou vous a aussi
parlé de solutions comme réfléchir se
rassembler mais surtout agir car
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]